so when you meet other filmmakers or you
receive maybe an email or something on
social media and they ask you a question
what question is that usually
um
well
all filmmakers independently are always
looking for
where can we get money that was like the
thing that we i think that was like the
question we got asked most when we were
in festivals it was like the first
question was like the first question
after our premiere sundance was how much
did your film cost and where did you get
the money i was kind of like really
that's what you you just sat and watched
this movie and that's what you want to
know um
a lot of filmmakers do want to
the question about money is one that
definitely seems to trouble a lot of
filmmakers
where do they get it from and it's it's
always a it's always like where did you
get the money yeah i always think it's
the least interesting question in a way
you know i just think god there's so
many more exciting things to talk about
when we talk about films but that is a
question that comes up a lot
where did you get the finances and the
runner-up question
um
how did you find your actors was a very
big one you know it was a big big
question normally that came from people
who were either actors or aspiring
actors
but for the most part it was it was
always like
where did you find your actors i mean
the performances were amazing how did
you find them what was
how did that come to be and then you
know when when we tell them that gainer
is a family friend a really close family
friend and
her husband also did the music he his
name is liam howe and he had a band
called the sneaker pimps and now he
produces music and he's doing diane's
second film as well
and then when we tell them that george
the character george is played by mike
picciarelli i mean i met him as a result
of the two of us talking about
hemingway books
and that was you know we met impromptu
and he saw i was reading the hemingway
book and we got chatting and
he that was how he got cast as the part
of george you know just here in los
angeles here in l.a and
he had come here from europe with his
wife and you know they were both
pursuing modeling
commercial
and acting careers and
you know this was his first big break
yeah
so those are the so the money is the
huge question people want to know actors
how to do that yeah
yeah money and actors that was the big
questions
you